la gráfica de una función f se muestra a
continuación si tanto el límite cuando x
tiende a k de fx como efe década
existente y f no es continua en cada
cual es el valor de k entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es encontrar puntos en
el dominio donde la función no sea
continua pero esté definida y además el
límite cuando x tiende a ese valor
también existe la condición que es más
fácil de hallar a simple vista es que f
no sea continua en k y vamos a ver esto
donde la función no es continua pues por
ejemplo aquí en menos 2 a quien menos 2
tengo una discontinuidad porque la
función viene por acá y parece que en
menos 2 va a valer 3 y medio pero aquí
salta salta y llega hasta este punto acá
abajo en menos 3 así que aquí hay una
discontinuidad
también hay una discontinuidad acá en 3
de nuevo la función parece que va a
valer como cuatro y medio y salta para
valer menos
cada uno de estos saltos es una
discontinuidad aquí en 8 también tengo
otra discontinuidad puesto que la
función parece venir por acá atendiendo
a uno pero aquí salta y vale siete así
que la función es discontinua en estos
tres puntos que serían nuestros tres
candidatos vamos a checar la segunda
condición que efe de que exista
efe decae tiene que existir en este caso
para el menos dos la función si existe
está definida aquí como menos tres algo
así entonces la función existe también
para tres la función existe está
definida aquí como 4.5 o 4.2 algo así
poco arriba de 4
y también para 8 la función existe está
definida aquí
y vale 7 así que realmente este
requisito no nos ayuda mucho el último
que nos falta por estudiar es que el
límite cuando x tiende a que también
tiene que existir así que veamos si me
fijo aquí en menos 2 y considero
aproximarme desde la izquierda entonces
la función parece entender a 3 punto
algo oa 3 digamos pero si me acerco
desde la derecha si me acerco de este
lado el límite parece ser menos 3 como
el límite izquierdo o el límite por la
izquierda no coincide con el límite por
la derecha entonces este límite no
existe que hay del límite cuando x
tiende a 3 pues por la izquierda parece
que la función se acerca a 4.5 o algo
similar
pero por la derecha la función parece
aproximarse a -4 así que aquí al límite
por la derecha y el límite por la
izquierda tampoco coinciden así que este
punto tampoco sirve todo indica que va a
ser el 8 que hay del límite por la
izquierda pues el límite por la
izquierda la función parece entender a 1
déjenme lo noto por acá el límite el
límite cuando x tiende a 8 por la
izquierda
fx es igual a 1 y el límite cuando x
tiende a 8 por la derecha
fx es cuanto pues por la derecha también
parece que nos acercamos a uno así que
como límite por la izquierda y el límite
por la derecha existen y son iguales
decimos que el límite cuando x tiende a
8 de fx
es igual a 1 así que el límite cuando x
tiende a 8 es 1 pero esto es distinto
esto es distinto que el valor de s en 8
así que la función no puede ser continua
y porque el límite el límite cuando x
tiende a 8 no es igual a la función
evaluar de noche así que f nos que no es
continua en 8 ya sabíamos eso y con todo
esto podemos decir que acá tiene que ser
igual a 8 porque satisface 8 satisface
todos nuestros requisitos